wir schauen jetzt auf schockierende
bilder aus london mehrere jüdische
passagiere sind auf dem weg zu einer
hanuta feier dem höchsten fest im
jüdischen glauben und während sie im bus
sitzen werden sie von passanten
beleidigt und angegriffen mehrere von
ihnen zeigen im mittelfinger und den
hitlergruß damit nicht genug einige
treten und spucken auch gegen den bus
sind widerliche szenen die einen
sprachlos machen unglaublich mit welchem
haus im jahr 2021 in aller
öffentlichkeit mitten im zentrum der
britischen hauptstadt einer
weltmetropole
juden angegangen werden dann bei uns im
studio ist bild lei chef claus strunz
klaus deinen kommentar ja also wir
müssen es benennen was es ist eine
schande eine katastrophe für alle die
sich vorstellen dass kulturen friedlich
nebeneinander und miteinander leben
können also für alle die integration
dieses wichtige mittel menschen
zusammenzubringen zu leichtfertig nehmen
das eigentlich beklemmende neben der
sache selbst da waren übrigens teenager
offensichtlich in dem bus also ein
angriff auf auf jugendliche so der
berufen free palestine damit ist auch
die absender schafft klar es ist also
sozusagen ein angriff von muslimischen
fanatikern auf jüdische teenager es muss
auch einmal ausgesprochen werden und es
muss berichtet werden weil was ich immer
vermisse ist warum ist das nicht in der
tagesschau warum ist das nicht in heute
warum ist das nicht in der bbc das habe
ich jetzt nicht gecheckt vielleicht ist
es damals in england war aber viele
vergleichbare taten werden immer nur ja
eigentlich nicht berichtet werden nicht
richtig notiz davon genommen dabei zeigt
uns das etwas was wirklich beklemmend
ist das ist das eigentlich aus deutscher
sicht falls jetzt irgendjemand denkt
dass doch in london was geht uns das an
es geht uns was an weil diese szenen
haben sich ja auch auf deutschen straßen
schon geeignet diese szenen kann man
auch in deutschland sozusagen nicht als
das gibt es nicht bezeichnen diese
szenen können stattfinden in berlin in
köln in essen und jetzt kommt es sehr
interessant ist sie können aber
eigentlich nicht stattfinden in warschau
in budapest und in prag und das ist
schon ganz interessant was ist denn da
der unterschied der unterschied ist eine
einwanderungs und zuwanderungspolitik
die spring die die strikter ist das muss
man nicht gut finden aber was man machen
muss wenn man viele menschen anderer
kulturen in sein eigenes land einreisen
und dort leben lässt ist dafür zu sorgen
dass sie die werte die hier gelten
akzeptieren und jugendliche wie die die
wir da gesehen haben in london und
jugendliche die das in deutschland
machen
akzeptieren diese werte nicht und das
ist das total versagen einem
integrationspolitik ich will sogar gar
nicht jetzt sagen diesen schuld und
diesen schritt und die sind schuld
eigentlich ist es das total versagen von
uns allen weil wir offensichtlich unser
wertesystem das ja in dieser frage auch
darauf beruht leben und leben lassen
also man lässt andere in ihrem glauben
leben man lässt andere mit ihrer
auffassung leben neben sich man freut
sich mit macht dann strebt ein
miteinander an aus diesem leben und
leben lassen ist offensichtlich leben
und leben lassen geworden und das ist
der gau der größte anzunehmende unfall
für integrationspolitik wenn ich diese
bilder sehen die wir jetzt aus london
gesehen haben und wenn ich mich an die
erinnert die es in deutschland schon gab
und hoffentlich nicht mehr geben wird
allein wenn man diesen satz ausspricht
glaubt man selber nicht daran es ist ja
morgen wieder möglich das ganze auch
noch an
jüdischen feiertagen ist mittlerweile so
dass immer wenn ein jüdischer feiertage
man sich sorgen machen muss dass es zu
einem antisemitischen übergriff kommt ja
wohl ewig denn ich denke wir leben in
einem land wo ganz klar ist wie die
regeln sind und wer sich nicht daran
hält der muss große probleme kriegen und
ich bin auch der meinung wird das was
wir hier sehen begeht muss viel härter
bestraft werden als das bislang der fall
ist wo man sich mit den sanktionen bei
antisemitischen straftaten und
antisemitischen taten sehr sehr schwer
tut